en lo último que nos quedamos estábamos
calculando las coordenadas de los
vértices de este teatro y pudimos
lograrlo este era el menos 100 el 100 el
0 raíz de 30 y el de arriba era el 0-3
entre 32 raíz de dos entre raíz de tres
y además pudimos calcular donde estaba
el centro de la base verdad y estaba
justamente aquí tiene estas coordenadas
ahora lo único que nos falta es
encontrar el centro de esta cara que más
o menos digamos estará ahí para poder
calcular esta distancia que aquí tenemos
marcada en rosa verdad que
correspondería justamente a esta
distancia una vez que tenemos eso
podemos hacer la proporción con el lado
grande y al elevarlo al cubo nos da la
proporción que hay entre los dos
volúmenes de los dos tetraedros así que
vamos vamos a encontrarlo
si puedes darte cuenta en este punto se
encuentra sobre el plano de zeta de
hecho déjame pintar aquí el eje zeta
digamos aquí está el eje z aunque quizás
lo va a poner punteado para que no se
confunda con él con él con el tetraedro
ahí lo tienen este es el eje z y este y
este punto se encuentra sobre el plano
que se está el generado por estos dos
ejes entonces vamos a calcularlo de
hecho lo podemos ver ahí mismo
simplemente tenemos que hacer el
promedio de estos tres vértices así que
la primera coordenada la primera
coordenada vamos digamos vámonos para
acá vamos este lo voy a lo voy a
calcular por acá que la primera
coordenada como es es menos uno más
menos uno más uno más cero entre tres
verdad estoy promediando las tres
coordenadas x luego voy a promediar las
coordenadas yes que es cero
0 + raíz de 3 entre 3 y todo esto entre
3 y finalmente vamos con las coordenadas
z 000 + 0 + 2 raíz de 22 raíz de 2 entre
la raíz de 3 y todo esto entre 3 muy
bien ahí están las coordenadas de este
punto simplemente vamos a vamos a tratar
de simplificar esto esto aquí tenemos
menos uno más uno es 0 +0 es cero y
entre 3 sigue siendo 0 y ahí está verdad
no tenemos coordenada x por lo tanto
está en el plano de zeta
ahora bien cuánto es 00 más raíz de 3
entre 3 pues sólo es raíz de 3 entre 3 y
si dividimos entre 3 tenemos raíz de 3
entre 9 muy bien y ahora tenemos 0 + 0
+2 raíz de 2 / raíz de 3 simplemente es
2 raíz de 2 / raíz de 3 y si dividimos
entre 3 nos queda 2
raíz de 2 entre 3 raíz de 3 ahí tienen
ustedes las coordenadas de este punto
que es uno de los vértices que nos van a
servir para calcular esta longitud del
tetraedro pequeño ahora vamos a calcular
la verdad como calculamos la longitud al
cuadrado esencialmente ya sabemos que es
como extender la idea del teorema de
pitágoras y entonces tenemos que el lado
pequeño al cuadrado
va a ser igual a quien a la diferencia
de las coordenadas de nuestros puntos
que va a ser este que acabamos de
obtener y el centro de la base que
entonces en las coordenadas x restamos 0
-0 verdad entonces 0 - 0 y elevamos al
cuadrado sumamos la diferencia de las
coordenadas yes que es raíz de 3 entre 3
raíz de 3 entre 3 menos
la raíz de 3 entre 9 y este déjenme
ponerlo como mejor como 3 raíz de 3
entre 9 muy bien 3 raíz de 3 entre 9
menos aquí tenemos raíz de 3 entre 9 y
lo anterior lo hice solo para que
tengamos el mismo denominador muy bien y
también voy a sumar la diferencia de las
coordenadas z que es 0 y 2 raíz de 2
entre 3 raíz de 3 aquí tendremos 2 raíz
de 2 entre 3 raíz de 3
pero al cuadrado muy bien esta es la
longitud al cuadrado vamos a ver qué es
eso entonces la longitud pequeña al
cuadrado será igual por un lado bueno
esto de aquí se hace cero verdad 0 - 0
al cuadrado es cero ahora quién es esto
aquí tenemos tres raíz de 3 entre 9
menos raíz de 3 entre 9 entonces en
realidad tenemos 2 raíz de 3 entre 9 2
raíz de 3 entre 9 déjenme anotarlo aquí
esto es 2 raíz de 3 entre 9 y eso hay
que elevarlo al cuadrado entonces
tenemos 4 por 3 entre 9 al cuadrado que
es 81 muy bien ok y vámonos con la
última parte esto de aquí
vamos a sumar 2 raíz de 2 entre 3 raíz
de 3 - 0 sigue siendo el mismo y al
elevarlo al cuadrado nos queda 4 por 2
entre 9 por 3 muy bien entre 9 por 3 y
ya simplemente tenemos que hacer esta
operación esto de aquí aquí podemos por
ejemplo cancelar un 3
y aquí nos queda 27 muy bien y entonces
tenemos 4 entre 27 más 8 entre 27 y como
tenemos mismo denominador podemos
simplemente sumar y son 12 sobre 27 y
esto simplemente si dividimos entre 3
arriba y abajo nos queda 4 entre 9 pero
esto es la longitud pequeña al cuadrado
así que lo que tenemos es que la
longitud
la longitud pequeña pequeña
así pequeña debe ser la raíz cuadrada de
esto y la raíz de 4 entre 9 2 sobre 3
muy bien entonces ya estamos muy cerca
de terminar el problema porque la
longitud pequeña es dos tercios y la
longitud grande cuánto es era dos era
dos verdad
la longitud grande era este lado que
mide dos entonces a esto al resolverlo
lo podemos elevar al cubo pero por
ejemplo aquí todavía podemos simplificar
verdad esto se puede hacer un 1 si
cancelamos entre 2 o si dividimos arriba
y abajo entre 2 y simplemente nos queda
1 entre un tercio y 1 entre un tercio es
3 esto es 3 verdad entonces esto
simplemente nos va a quedar como esto
simplemente va a ser 27 al cubo 27 entre
1 al que no ya ya de al cubo ya lo
efectuamos verdad aquí es uno entre un
tercio nos queda 3 y al cubo es 27 que
lo podemos ver como 27 entre 1
pero dijimos que la proporción entre
estos es m / n así que esto es m / n muy
bien y 27 y 1 ya son primos relativos
así que si nos tomamos a m como 27 tiene
como 1 ya tenemos eso ya tenemos eso y
simplemente tenemos que m n serán 27 más
1 que son 20 8 y ahí está la respuesta a
este problema